which is part of why i decided to go
with ant-man interesting because he
opens that movie not having custody of
his child
and we'll get to that but first i just
want to take you guys over to the board
real quick
now oh my god
our world is full of gadgets the apple
watch some other kind of fancy watch
that's not as good as the apple watch
and air fryers i hear those are pretty
cool
but the folks in the mcu have got us
beat in the gizmo department who
wouldn't trade in all their air fryers
for just one infinity gauntlet
i'm here with tom and nina to ask what's
the most useful mco
power or gadget for everyday life did
you just equate the infinity gauntlet
with an air fryer
i mean i know so much more than that
he set up an exchange rate yeah
one air fryer for an infinity gauntlet
that so you can
air fry like really quickly so fast just
needed
one air fryer i think one of the reasons
why he was so upset in that movie was
because he was just hungry
if someone had air fried him some curly
fries some arby's curly fries
yeah he's a big boy yeah listen
i want an air fryer okay and my wife
won't let me have it but i'm gonna get
one
and all i have is this damn infinity gum
i'll take an air fryer or an infinity
gauntlet there has to be a better way
so my pick oh man for the most useful
mcu it's an airfryer
it's not an airflow well we haven't seen
any air fryers i have seen nina
so as far as i know tony stark hasn't
built one yet
got it um my pick is actually
the web shooters that's spider-man
i really want web shooters
and not to swing around town because i
don't have spider powers and if i tried
doing that i would die
what i want the web shooters for is when
i'm sitting
and there's something over there and i
don't want to get up i want to be able
to do a
pap and just get the thing
and sometimes also when my kid he's at
the stage now he's almost
two so when you change his diaper he
really likes doing this with his legs
where he's just like wow legs everywhere
so if you could just
like hold those still with some web
shooters yeah
web the baby up change that diaper can't
wait for your kid to watch one day
listen he needs to know that changing a
diaper
not fun should be easy it should be easy
it was easier when he i
used to think this is going to get so
much easier when he's older and he's not
like no
i can reason with him no no they become
kung fu fighters as they age yeah
yeah so if i had web shooters no longer
a problem
yeah and you know sometimes people are
talking when you're trying to watch
something
just shut them up there's an important
piece of dialogue little web shooter to
the mouth that's a good one just like
your now your nose is open you know i
left the nostrils open you can still
breathe
but please i really we've rewound this
part like three times i still can't hear
them
because you keep talking yeah so that's
my pick
that's so you can get a glimpse into my
life i'm lazy
i'm easily annoyed by people talking and
i don't like my son very much
and you want everything you own to be
just a little stickier
i just want everything to be covered in
a thin film
of stickiness gross so that way no one
will touch it right everyone will be
like
no there's no better home security in
the world than just everything
at this rate you won't have any friends
or family around
yeah cause they'll because i will have
i'll have web their faces whenever we
try
or they'll be like i'm thinking of
living in a gently sticky home
yes there's just like websites
everything feels like you poured pepsi
on it at a picnic
try it out so that's my pick for the
most
peaceful gadget in everyday life nina
what's your pick
mine's eerily similar in that it comes
down to the fact that i'm really lazy
i don't like to do things or get up or
move around
i really don't like to clean um
i i'm not a person who like i wish that
i were a neat freak
that's my deepest wish so in that vein i
would not say no to tony stark's
like smart house and i know that we all
learned about the dangers of a smart
house from the disney channel original
movie
smart house but directed by lavar burton
yeah
correct but tony seems like he's ironed
out the kinks of like the house maybe
trying to kill you or anything
and you know he never really has to do
anything and it just seems to keep
itself in order and there's never just
like
i don't think tony stark lives the way
that i do where there's just
like a pile of clothes that aren't dirty
enough to wash
but that you know you're gonna re-wear
so it's just on your hamper
or like he doesn't have a clothes chair
in his room like gray clothes that's
what i really have some
gray clothes yeah so it's just like i
just would love a house
that you know obeys my every command
does all the work for me and i don't
have to do stuff
so i would take tony stark's cool smart
house tony stark's smart house yeah i
like that answer a lot and then you have
like
the robot can be on hand with the fire
extinguisher yeah yeah
so when you have a grease fire you don't
have to be like how do you stop a grease
fire
right i don't have a fire extinguisher i
mean i
i hopefully won't be starting that many
grease fires it's not something i i ate
the answer is you throw kosher salt at
it
really is that a fact that's something i
had to do
yikes threw a coat yourself into fire i
well i had a grease fire and then i was
like the fire extinguisher doesn't work
because
it came with the house and it was really
old right i've gotten a new one
oh my god my wife was like you could
throw salt at it and i was like
okay so then i threw a bunch of salt at
it and it worked and then the food was a
little saltier but
we didn't die so that was good but if i
had spider-man's web shooters
you could just web that thing i could do
yeah web up the fire right isn't the
web does that work i don't think that
works i don't think that works whatever
you want it to be baby but if i'd had
tony stark's smart home it wouldn't have
been maybe
the robot has a fire extinguisher in its
hand doesn't even need it like
yeah yeah it's just ready to go
yeah okay plus real estate's just a good
investment yeah
and i think i could flip that smart
house later if i wanted to yeah
it's a great it's a great beautiful
house right on
yeah great natural lighting the house
listens to you when you talk
yeah i also live by myself so it'd be
kind of dope if i could just chat with
my house sometimes
you just want to you just want a buddy
yeah to live in your house
i think you just i mean you have a dog
yeah you just need um
[Music]
totally get i got an alexa specifically
so i'd have somebody
we hey alexa
back me up on this oh tom is 100
right on this i can't hear what she's i
didn't know never mind
she was backing me up on that on that
note tom what are your picks for the
most useful
power gadget from the mcu for everyday
life
guys i want to apologize i didn't put a
ton of thought into this one
uh i think you guys know this about i'm
not really
big into geek stuff
more of a sports man clearly
yeah by yourself to my thank you
uh i rent it
to my eyes most of the avengers powers
just come off
as things that are gonna get brought up
in family court later when your ex is
trying to
make sure you don't have custody of your
kids anymore like
oh he gets angry and breaks things like
if you've got a thor hammer it's like he
hits things with a hammer
he's always carrying his hammer yeah and
it's really weird
really unsafe around the kids it's very
thin exactly
yeah so like there's a lot of
opportunities to just not have custody
of your children anymore
which is part of why i decided to go
with
ant-man interesting because he opens
that movie not having custody of his
child
and we'll get to that but first i just
want to take you guys over to the board
real quick
now oh my god
if you'll just take a look right here i
think you'll see number one parking you
can't find a parking space boom
no problem tiny car let's say that
you're moving into a new apartment and
there are size restrictions on the dog
that you can bring into the apartment
with you right
tiny doc by the same token maybe your
dog is too confident maybe it's getting
a little bit too big for its bridges
make it too small for its bridges oh my
god
let's say that you have a big talent
show coming up and you need to blow the
door off the hinges with the piano solo
but all you have is one of those little
tiny
uh uh who's the kid from peanuts
schroder
schroeder you have a little tiny
schroeder piano but you need a big one
that solves that problem or
other way around you're raising a child
to be like schroeder but all you have is
a giant piano you can make it smaller
shredder size oh my god
historically ant men have been able to
hang out with evangeline lilly which is
cool because you could be the first
person to recreationally understand what
happened
in gloss this is important you get to
talk
to ants i don't feel like we we discuss
that enough and what that means is
as long as your home is disgusting you
will always have a friend
i don't want the smart house anymore i
want this thank you so i think i'm
making some compelling arguments also i
think it's important to remember that
like throughout the entire mcu
and also the comics ant-man has always
had the coolest
accoutrements and this is the most
important part of all
because i think that you guys will
remember and once again i'm not into
geeks though
but
in mike allred matt fraction's seminal
2013 work
ff it was established that pym particles
work on a tri-axial mechanism right it's
a three-dimensional map
and the matter can change it's not only
its size and its strength but also its
durability right
whereas in the mcu all that we have is
this very
inconsistent mechanism by which somebody
gets
small and retains their original
strength but then they get big
and also stronger and also the the
durability of the object somehow also
increases like are you saying that a one
ounce
thomas the tank engine toy when expanded
to the size of a school bus would have
structural stability to knock out the
wall of the house it doesn't make any
sense right
what does that mean no rules it means
there's no rules you guys
nothing makes sense that means the
ant-man's real power isn't getting
bigger and smaller
it's just doing whatever needs to happen
in the movie and i think
that that is the ultimate power
well tom that's pretty good but i really
do wish that you had prepared a little
bit yeah
it's kind of embarrassing i know it's
like nina and i came locked and loaded
with our answers
and i just feel like it's kind of
unprofessional that you would come here
without having prepared as well
i don't know why you hired this guy he
clearly doesn't know anything about the
mcu
i mean i believe in second chances tom
next time i want you to try a little bit
harder
to be ready to go okay
all right bye
thanks for joining us please hit like
and subscribe so you don't miss a single
new episode